[Music]
and better sex news I like this one
oh how can it even get bad Scorpio knows
I was called for 10 nice fratres oh yeah
where's Cooper sue no I'm a Sagittarius
Bo's a month
is submitted by I'm a virgin
I like those those 300 in something days
without sex things that are happening
right now
oh yeah there's like funny Oh what is it
those are like definitely yeah not made
by Scorpios I think and if there are no
sex challenge
no they're just I think it's cool though
it's like funny memes that are happening
oh yeah so it's something that's like
not sexual that they make it kind of
sexual and they just joke right now
gotta hear it can't hear yet come on
what make one right now Oh like there's
so there's a picture of a dude and he's
sitting on top of like this these these
poles right and one of this pulls this
high but the one that he's sitting on is
this low but it looks like it's in his
ass like 360 something days without sex
ah like the first yeah
it's quenched I get it that's funny
through rubbing your genitals in sexual
there on things that is hilarious
I enjoy a new study reports that men
have better sex with emotionally
unstable women no wonder I like all
women kind of emotionally insane
depending on what time of the month
some want someone more unstable or I
could see that I've dated some pretty
crazy girls that in the relationship I
didn't know that they were crazy we had
great sex but then later I was like holy
[ __ ] you know you know why I think it's
because they're also very beautiful so
I'm like sometimes I attribute beauty to
crazy a great sight all the time a lot
of the times I think like I think if
you're a beautiful woman you have to
like really work through some stuff
because you're just like beautiful so
like you have an advantage do you're
assuming that they were said to be
beautiful they're whole did I say that I
did I so didn't I start off by saying
this is not always the case
oh it's it's even more simpler than that
the spirits
played a curse the spirits played the
curse on a beautiful woman but I'll make
you beautiful as [ __ ] I'm gonna give you
a lot of baggage I'm also saying it for
my experience but I feel like that's not
always the case man I feel like I feel
like once I like really work through my
[ __ ] I started like maybe attracting
better less crazier girls better people
yeah yeah but like at the time that I
was your partner is reflective of where
you are at that time when you're messing
around with the crazy girl you're not
really looking to settle down with them
you're looking for something else
because when I was like 17 I wanted a
girl that had a rap sheet and had
[ __ ] tattoos all over her body you
know I think at that time if she bought
me a gun for my birthday I would I would
have been my favorite like you're my
girl like we're getting married like
that's just a silly little scratch stuff
yep unstable you use like anybody that
becomes a gambling addict or yeah
alcoholic it's like some women might
become sex addicts and like if you have
a lot of sex you obviously naturally
become better at it but that doesn't
always I don't think emotionally
unstable equates to better sex I just
think that maybe some women get better
at sex because they're using that as
like a escape mechanism and then all
right just feel like emotionally
unstable women would just do anything in
bed and so you can get snap juice here's
what I think yes to add to that because
they're not reserved so when they're
emotionally unstable that means they
don't have self-control so they're
licking all over you because they don't
have control they just they just do
whatever they feel and he just [ __ ]
go hard you know and then that's true
and then if you are more you could be
emotion stable and really like having
sex and are really good at it and then
have a good sex
I'm not saying that they can't do that
in control you're yeah but they're but
they're controlling themselves we're not
out of control it's a way that you find
a partner what they want a partner where
you both are so in tune with like each
other's like if you guys control levels
are the same I think that's dope but I
think nothing's better than out of
control everything so then are we saying
that this [ __ ] is bogus no I'm hearing
no I'm saying it could be true but then
it doesn't mean that there's caviar it
doesn't mean that but you can all
have good sex yeah if a woman is
emotional yeah there's no blanket
statements but this is as fun as
horoscopes that's all I got to say sure
or if the woman is on drugs
I used to gettin arguing with my girl
all the time and like we just like like
colleges emotions and everything and
then after that we just have amazing sex
because I think it was just a release no
I just get angry and tired and I go to
sleep because I yell so much I get tired
do do you have sex in the same day as
argument same like the same with the
next hour if I fight with the woman that
I'm with the sex is not on the table you
are the most disgusting creature to me
I've ever seen my what say I'm sorry mr.
Ebner oh well you could explain it to
him I was saying I've never had makeup
sex because of what David thought to say
which was basically it's if I hate you
and you've pissed me off you are [ __ ]
disgusting to me you get the [ __ ] away
me too
I realize that now like it's not worth
me wanting to like sustain a
relationship even whether it be sexual
or whatever like with a girl if like I
don't like resonate with you anymore so
like I've learned to like be like I
can't have this girl or this person in
my life anymore just because we don't
see eye to eye on a lot of things it's
like it's not worth it just for the just
to have good snack good sex I'm like I
had to separate the gym like I can still
have good sex with up to Stableford so
sometimes like depending on who you're
with they're like makeup sex I'm like
you know I still have remnants of me
hating you so don't touch me man but
that's that's that's I respect that
gives us a lot of self-control it's not
so good yeah I know cuz you won't let
you won't let the sex cloud your your
judgment of like what's good for you
she's just like butt naked I'm like nope
I'm still angry that's great what's up
guys more of a pride thing like now he's
just being prideful I can't back down
that's not pie boys it's more like no
I'm still my pride is bigger than my
dick no that's another t-shirt right
maybe if you're not like if you're not
like I hate you I'm nine houses mayor's
like you know what I did this nah I
don't want this said it's cool you do
you I wanna do me that's it
my pride is bigger than my dick I
believe that from now on when the fight
happens I'm gonna get that t-shirt this
is my pride is bigger than my take it on
rip it up
you know why his pride is bigger than my
dick it's under your shirt every day all
right so this thing here that was this
survey this German survey of a thousand
people so what they found it so first of
all none of them study then the aunt you
do what the Germans have done oh yeah
I'm with it I'm with it all right
not soon enough for women this survey
included sexual desire satisfaction
arousal and orgasm for men a focus on
erectile function desired satisfaction
orgasm and what they concluded here is
that men have better sex with women who
are emotionally unstable and women
prefer men who are less agreeable but
pay attention to detail and I'm a woman
oh yeah less agreeable so an argument if
man that pays attention to the small
things I don't know if has to be
arguments it but maybe like less
agreeable in terms of like you he stands
his ground kind of thing like you want
your suck my dick like it's like hey
we're gonna do this justice like you
want somebody to like give an opinion to
our women usually like that though they
want some we take them I don't think
they want a yes man all the time I don't
often I was dating a girl that was like
got mad at me for like being like why
don't you just tell me what to do all
the time I was like what you want that
you want me to do that oh like tell me
what you're gonna do this and this and
this and it tell me like you know don't
give me the option to say or even if I
say no but like we're gonna do it anyway
and also cookie you're crazy
will we go home [ __ ] you punch me my
mouth okay it's the same crazy girl I'm
driving
we're late a little to that so I must be
crazy to another boat echo sometimes but
on a crazy level I would say you're
being like I would like a guy for me to
him to plan out of it you're definitely
not that girl you just want to got a
plan on an evening you'll be nice I
think you want let's do this let's go
I'll do that in a blue moon she's like
she wanted a guy to be like we're doing
this and then I was like why can't you
spit up my [ __ ] face every now and
then huh [ __ ] kind of a Maura here with
the [ __ ] normal s dry face dude
you're looking at this you're looking at
this all wrong dude like you could eat
whatever you want do what hang it like
you could go let's do balling let's eat
this let's do that she's like ooh would
she be cooler or would she'd be like I
don't want to do that all the time like
you just plan on everything
stop try to figure out cuz I was also I
was being very like no I'm you know what
I'm gonna help her work through her
stuff and then I know at a point I had
to realize that I'm like I can't
sacrifice myself for someone that's not
willing to change and if they were
willing to change you just prove this
thing girl
you proved the car right I said that I
said that but but but like I also
believe we can have a great relationship
mmm stable and you're both working
together to grow and learn yeah
cultivate or day whether you're whether
you know what do you two mature people
come along and if two mature people come
along they could do that they could be
good they can make that happen great
sense yes I think sex is also is is like
if you're if you're more like
emotionally spiritually aligned with
somebody and you're willing to learn and
that's that next level tantric
that's exactly that's what I'm trying to
learn about Indian man I get you inching
the Kama Sutra yeah but it's like that
sex is ass like it's just a distraction
it's just so ya know I eat everything
mrs. Erna it's like fighting it's like
because one is crack cocaine you still
get an adrenaline rush you're biting and
that's that same adrenaline from like
sex it's like yep
not that it's healthy it's a release the
release at the moment yeah what is one
is jacking off to regretful porn and the
other is having a
connection with someone that's on the
next level has had something they've
jerked out for that out for have been
like one example what is this what am i
becoming and then you're just saying
we're just like maybe I just need to do
that just to get that out before I don't
talk about it let's just keep that
between guys is your [ __ ] is out there I
feel like what my regretful porn is
nothing compared to where your ears are
no now we got a no I don't know I don't
even think I've ever had one Kressel
porn I think for me to like jackoff I
have to be I have to be around and
turned on by that and in order for me to
be turned on it already has to be
something I like and I've never yeah
it's not regrets it's not regrets
it's shame what's dad you know I told
you okay okay so so so I thought I
thought I was watching lesbian porn
right and then the girl goes down and
then a big fat dick comes out she just
goes down and I was like oh wait like oh
my god my dick is hard I was like I like
this did you bust nuts - I finished okay
and I cuz I said to myself like it's
still straight still between a man and a
woman but I also like lesbian porn dude
looks like a girl that's what you're
saying but it's like I get the best of
both worlds you don't even know you
watch this right that's regretful part I
want to click the way no no cuz you know
what I was thinking about it right I was
like okay I was like look when I'm
watching straight porn I don't know why
they go straight to the guy's face when
he comes why do they ruin it for me I
don't want to see the guy's face I just
want a [ __ ] ball and dick because I'm
pretending to be that guy you know like
I don't want to see anything else like
that this is a human being right but now
I get to check out this hot girl but
this hot girl has a [ __ ] dick by
blown silly
exactly that's not even a threesome I
get it a part of the body that that I
want to see in a porno is it's the half
male body but I get two girls now yes
sent me a link this is crazier than mine
is my my like hold what the hell am i
doing was like first time seeing like an
older Indian woman in porn because I was
like but wait that's an aunty to me you
have to be respectful I can't I can't
find her I was like what if I become
good that's my thing it's like what did
you buy society it's like cougar and
milk porn it's totally normal yeah yeah
I was like oh my god I just jerked off
to it an Indian woman over 40 and that's
a that's my aunty I can't what that was
my like what if I become you don't have
to buy you two senior mine is very like
guilt-ridden
in a custom tradition and I was like you
can't look at an older and I was like
Indian I'd be bored I was like oh my god
then it's not as that is not the ID
anymore Millford is normal yeah yeah so
Indian milf porn was like really weird
because I was like you've never seen
Indian women in that context that's true
sexuality in ER yeah they're not
sexualized it's the board for Indian
people sex is worse than killing
somebody I cannot watch I could not
especially when you have a religious
skill and you know traditional guilt and
you have custom guilt there's so many
levels of sexual guilt in our in our
culture where it's like sex was just
like and like it's I think it's even
more for me because when I was younger I
got caught looking at a Sears catalog
like the broad pay anything and I got
the [ __ ] beat anatomy oh wow I think I
have even a deeper sexual trauma because
I was like that like taught me at a
really young age is like sex is no big
it's a bad thing and like I was shamed
of my family and like I brought all my
family murmurs my uncle's not talking to
me my grandma didn't talk really and I
was just isolated I was like this is bad
this so I was like sexual trauma was
like a really bad thing for a lot of
people this is and this is not like a
special just me story there's a lot of
people that have this story especially
brown girls and girls have
even worse you know what sucks about
that too I think specifically like not
any in people but you know people like
Muslims Muslim students that's like the
worst because some of them are the
biggest pieces of [ __ ] but they'll still
ostracize somebody in public but in
their private life they're such garbage
you know it's like I'll give the odd a
thing in sexual like sexual things well
yeah it's like the worst be God it's all
a facade it's not like I have to be this
for this and it's like no you're a human
being
everybody is sexuality is integral part
of being a human being it shouldn't be
like so the more you you don't express
it the more you try to control it but
that's yeah it makes it worse
that's why I think in India I think I'm
like why why is sexuality like people
are just getting a rape all the time
there's a lot of rape cases in India I'm
like why is that I'm like there has to
be a part of it has to do with dudes not
be like and nobody's able to sexually
express themselves because it's like
Seoul is they can in Catholic Church
it's yo you know what I don't say like I
relate to a lot of like Muslims and
Catholic hits because I've gone through
that same set down saying and then it
like it becomes unhealthy then you have
like preset and less kids yeah because
and it's the same thing and like Muslim
yeah like strict religious families
you'll have like this happened because
people aren't able to express themselves
sexually in a healthy way and then they
just become weird and yes they should
just embrace like sex and porn like
Japan and then you'll have Pokemon and
fun stuff that's why I'm like the
Japanese are way ahead of they're like
30 years ahead of everybody else
you know there's nurses out there that
help jackoff people with disabilities
because they can't jack themselves off
anyone and and other cultures would be
like that's bad but like if to
consensual parties are like that's cool
and they're okay with you it's a
government fun to say that's wrong it's
government-funded like the nurses come
over and [ __ ] beat off the dude yeah
and it's like it's even in this like
society it's like it's still taboo you
that's that's wrong it's like and for me
I feel like all those ladies should have
a Medal of Honor
[Music]